>> AS THE CRISIS AT THE BORDER
APPEARS TO WORSEN VIRTUALLY BY
THE WEEK ACCORDING TO THE DATA,
REPUBLICANS ARE ACCUSING
KAMALA HARRIS OF GOING M.I.A.,
MISSING IN ACTION.
GUT WRENCHING IMAGES ARE SHOWING
CHILDREN AND CAGES AT A
FACILITY, THE PHOTOS COME FROM
TEXAS DEMOCRAT HENRY CUELLAR.
THIS IS THE MEDIA REMAINS LOCKED
DOWN.
PRESIDENT BIDEN PAST
VICE PRESIDENT HARRIS TO LEAD
THE RESPONSE LAST WEEK AND SO
FAR SHE HAS NOT ANNOUNCED PLANS
TO TRAVEL TO THE BORDER.
REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN BRIAN
BABIN IS AMONG THOSE PUSHING FOR
A VISIT SOONER RATHER THAN
LATER.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> WE HAVE INVITED
VICE PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS TO
ATTEND SOME OF OUR ITINERARY AND
SEE FOR HERSELF.
WE THOUGHT IT WOULD BE A GOOD
THING TO DO, FOR HER TO SEE
EXACTLY WHAT IS GOING ON DOWN
THERE SINCE IN THE PAST SHE
THOUGHT PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HIS
POLICIES WERE CRUEL AND INHUMANE
AND THEY WERE PUTTING CAGES IN
CAGES.
WE HAVE NOT HEARD YET, BUT WE
ARE HOPING SO.
>> LAST WEEK AT
PRESIDENT BIDEN’S FIRST
WHITE HOUSE PRESS CORE BRIEFING,
HE ANNOUNCED WHAT HE HAS NOT
TAKEN A TRIP, LIKE MOST DISASTER
AREAS A PRESIDENTIAL VISIT
REQUIRES A WHOLE HECK OF A LOT
MORE PLANNING ON THE GROUND.
IT DISTRACTS FROM THE EMERGENCY
RESPONSE.
HE SAID HIS GOVERNMENTS AND
CRISIS TRYING TO DEAL WITH THIS
SURGE OF PEOPLE, BUT DOES THAT
EXPLANATION SCRATCH THE ITCH?
>> IT DOES NOT AROSE WE WOULDN’T
SEE ANY PRESIDENT AT ANY AREAS
OF CRISIS AND THAT IS WHAT THE
PRESIDENT’S JOB IS.
IMAGINE BEING THE PRESIDENT OR
THE VICE PRESIDENT, WHAT IS THE
FIRST THING YOU DO?
YOU GET ON AN AIRPLANE AND GO TO
THE AFFECTED AREA.
PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID DURING THE
INAUGURATION THAT HE WOULD BE
THE PRESIDENT FOR ALL PEOPLE AND
IF YOU ASKED THE BORDER PATROL
OR THE FOLKS LIVING ALONG THE
SOUTHERN BORDER THEY WOULD SAY
HE IS FAILING AT THAT JOB.
I SPOKE TO A RANCHER AND
NEW MEXICO THIS MORNING AND HE
SAID WHILE CHILDREN AND FAMILY
UNITS ARE GETTING ATTENTION HE
IS SEEING GROUPS OF YOUNG MALE
MIGRANTS WALKING PAST HIS HOUSE
EVERY NIGHT AND BORDER PATROL
HAS TOLD HIM TO BE CAREFUL ON
HIS OWN PROPERTY.
PRESIDENT BIDEN FEELS LIKE HE
CAN’T GO DOWN THERE BECAUSE THEN
IT WOULD CAUSE, IT WOULD MEAN HE
WOULD BE ADMITTING THAT THIS IS
A CRISIS THAT RISES TO THE LEVEL
OF A PRESIDENTIAL VISIT.
ONE THING HE CAN DO QUICKLY IS
IMPLEMENT REIMPLEMENT MEXICO,
BUT HE’S PROBABLY NOT GOING TO
DO THAT BECAUSE THAT WOULD MEAN
HIS POLICIES WERE RIGHT AND HIS
WERE WRONG.
WE HAVE LEARNED YESTERDAY THAT
BORDER PATROL THINKS THIS CRISIS
IS GOING TO LAST FOR SEVEN
MONTHS.
THAT MEANS THIS IS GOING TO BE
SEVEN MONTHS OF PEOPLE COMING
INTO THE COUNTRY, VERY
EXPENSIVE, AND SEVEN MONTHS OF
PEOPLE CLAIMING ASYLUM WHO DON’T
LEGITIMATELY HAVE ASYLUM CLAIMS
AND THAT CREATES A BACKLOG FOR
PEOPLE WHO DO BELONG HERE FOR
REASONS THAT AFFECT THEIR OWN
PERSONAL SAFETY.
>> I WANT TO BRING YOU IN HERE
BECAUSE I’M GUESSING YOU DON’T
SEE THE SITUATION THE SAME WAY
THAT CARLY JUST LAID OUT.
TELL US HOW YOU SEE IT.
>> I WOULDN’T SAY THAT.
AMERICANS, WHETHER THEY ARE
DEMOCRATIC OR REPUBLICAN REALIZE
WE HAVE A PROBLEM.
WE HAVE DEMOCRATS AND
REPUBLICANS THAT SAY THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT’S BEEN KICKED
DOWN THE ROAD.
I DON’T THINK AND I WOULD HOPE
THE VICE PRESIDENT IS NOT
M.I.A., BUT WORKING ON WHAT IS
GOING TO BE THE STRATEGY AND THE
POLICY DEALING WITH THE NORTHERN
TRIANGLE NATIONS, DEALING WITH
MEXICO, AND THE ROOT CAUSE.
UNTIL WE DEAL WITH THE ROOT
CAUSE, WE HAVEN’T BEEN ABLE TO
FOR 17 YEARS.
ONE OF THE REASONS BORDER PATROL
CAN SAY, THIS WILL HAPPEN IN THE
NEXT SEVEN MONTHS IS BECAUSE
THEY KNOW WHAT IT’S LIKE
HISTORICALLY WHEN THE WEATHER
WARMS UP AND WHEN WE DON’T HAVE
WINTER.
AND ALSO, COVID NUMBERS ARE
REDUCING IN COUNTRIES THROUGHOUT
THE WORLD.
THE BOTTOM LINE, I DO THINK THE
VICE PRESIDENT SHOULD GO TO THE
BORDER.
IT COULD BE SOME LOGISTICAL
PROBLEM LIKE THE PRESIDENT HAD
NOT GOING TO THE BORDER.
I THINK SHE SHOULD TELL US, BUT
MORE SO IT’S BETTER IF SHE TELLS
US, OKAY, I’VE MET WITH THE
LEADERS OF THESE NATIONS, THIS
IS WHAT WE’VE CONCLUDED AND WHAT
WE PLAN TO DO.
>> SOMEBODY WHO WANTS TO GO TO
THE BORDER AND SAYS THEY WILL GO
SOON, FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP.
HE TOLD US THAT ON SATURDAY
NIGHT.
MY QUESTION, WE ALL KNOW THAT
FORMER PRESIDENTS ARE NOT
SUPPOSED TO INTERFERE WITH
CURRENT PRESIDENT’S FOREIGN
POLICY.
REPUBLICANS LOVE THE IDEA THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL GO TO THE
BORDER, SO HOW DOES HE DO THAT,
AVOID THE IMPRESSION THAT HE’S
MEDDLING?
>>>> THAT PLAYBOOK NO LONGER EXI
BECAUSE BARACK OBAMA BROKE THAT
PROGRAM, HE VIOLATED THAT POLICY
OF STAYING QUIET.
I THINK IT’S IMPORTANT, WHAT
DONALD TRUMP DID WAS PROVIDE
NATIONAL SECURITY.
CHRIS WALLACE ASKED JEN PSAKI
ABOUT WHETHER OR NOT ROLLING
BACK THE TRUMP POLICY HURTS THIS
COUNTRY.
SHE COULD NOT GIVE HIM ANY
CREDIT.
OUR BORDER WAS SECURE AND LAST
WEEK JOE BIDEN LIED TO THE
AMERICAN PUBLIC WHEN HE SAID
MORE PEOPLE, MORE ILLEGAL ALIENS
ARE RETURNING BACK TO THEIR OWN
COUNTRY.
THAT’S A LIE!
WE HAVE BEEN BOMBARDED.
NOT ONLY WHO HAVE COVID, BUT
THEY ARE GIVEN HOTEL ROOMS AND
ACCOMMODATIONS UNLIKE OUR